I think your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggled the most
with is what you want to help other
people through so I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur and get my first
business off the ground and quitting and
having $300 a month and all this stuff
and so I just want to try to make the
road a little bit easier for other
entrepreneurs to not have to struggle as
much as I did there's so many great
causes in the world but what's the one
that you're going to want to commit to
well it's the one that you feel most
connected to you don't care about
entrepreneurs and cool don't worry about
entrepreneurs focus on the thing that
you care about the most so that's you
know I think everybody needs to stars
with purpose cuz if you woke up and felt
like you're going to do something today
that matters because it's serving
somebody else you're much more likely to
stay consistent you know I've started in
2009 so there been a lot of making
videos over the years why why do I stay
consistent because I still feel
connected to the purpose of what I'm
doing need motivation watch your top 10
with believe Nation hey it's EV car
Michael and I make these videos because
I need them because being around
successful entrepreneurs who are pushing
who are driving who are doing amazing
things gives me that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning every day to help me go off and
accomplish great things too and I hope
that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's learn
from one of the best my husband Evan
carmichel in our take on his top 10
rules for Success
enjoy why is it necessary that one word
for brending your business so I think it
comes in two forms I think it starts
with you I think it gives you the clear
perspective on what your brand is all
about I think a lot of times when people
coming up with a brand they don't you
know they're they're picking something
because it looks nice or it sounds good
but it's not coming from a really deep
place of meaning and the brand needs to
mean something first to you like you
need to be proud of everything that
you're creating and it has to have a has
to have a heartbeat everything you make
has to have a heartbeat whether that's a
creating content or or creating the
service like you do coaching you do
Consulting that has to you have to help
people thrive in in those sessions or
you're not going to be you know happy
about that um and so it it gives you a
frame of reference for yourself first
and then that flows through everything
flows into your entire business how you
operate your company uh you know you
want to bring on people to your team who
believe in similar things as you do if
you're hiring a video editor you know my
video editor wanted to tattoo believe on
her arm before she even met
me she she you know she believes in the
same thing and so you want bring people
on who have the skill set but also
believe the same thing that you believe
and if you don't know what you believe
then you'll attract anybody but if
you're really specific on what you
believe then it's easy to bring people
in who are on the same Mission that's an
internal brand most people look at the
external which we can get to but like
that's the internal brand you need the
internal Compass because if the external
is one thing and the internal is
something else you're not going to be
happy you're going to feel like a fake
you're going to feel like you're always
having to live up to something that
you're not the external then is what
people perceive it as what when people
see your your content when people see
your product or service your your
branding your your Instagram and YouTube
and all of that what do they think what
do they feel if it's too complicated you
know they won't be able to share it
people people could love your stuff but
if they can't articulate it clearly to
their friends and their colleagues
they're not going to share it I think
of uh corporations that have their 13
core values that nobody actually knows
nobody shares it because it's too
complicated like if you need me to
remember five things about you to share
it I'm not going to it's just even if I
love you like I'd have to love you
insanely a lot to remember those five
things but if it's if it's one thing and
people know me for belief they want more
Bel in their life it's you should talk
to Evan you should go watch his YouTube
channel you should subscribe to him you
should check out what he's doing it's
just easy to remember because people
have busy lives it's not that they don't
want to talk about you you're just
making it too complicated you're
introducing too much friction to them
what is the entrepreneurial mindset how
do they think wow I think it I think it
roots from a a dissatisfaction with the
world around us uh entrepreneurs are The
Crazy Ones who see a better future are
upset about something and then we want
to make a change where I think anybody
can pick out something that they don't
like in their world but the
entrepreneurs are the solution providers
they're the ones who want to find a way
to solve it and to make the world a
better place somehow and I think most of
our Global problems could be solved by
entrepreneurs they were given the
opportunity a feeling that I have the
power to be able to make a change where
I think a lot of people who might be
inside a a corporation or an
organization they see a problem with how
their organization is run if you're you
know you work at a library you see tons
of problems with the library but then
you feel oh I can't do this because I
don't have the power it's not my
position it's not my job title where the
entrepreneurial mindset is I'm going to
find a way to make a difference I'm
going to find a way to make a change if
I don't like something at this Library
I'm going to step up and do something
even though it's not not my position uh
and so I think adopting that mindset and
just that ability to feel like I'm
empowering myself I don't need
permission from somebody else to say
what I can and cannot do I'm going to do
something to try to make a positive
impact and uh one for the individuals in
the organization to feel like they can
go and take that leap and then two for
the leaders of those organizations to
empower their team to take risk and do
something different and not say you can
only do what's inside this box something
you say that I love is is that you can't
out Evan Evan I want to know what you
mean by that yeah I think a lot of times
we we have role models we have mentors
and there's nothing wrong with it I love
I've learned a lot from the people in my
life and people have profiled on my
channel uh but it it's easy to turn into
impostor syndrome to feel like well I'm
never going to be as good as whoever
like you're here starting this podcast
uh and you might look at Joe Rogan or
Tim Ferris or whoever whoever you think
is the best podcaster interviewer out
there but the goal is never to be Joe
Rogan the goal is to be the best Samuel
possible and that is an evolution and
even at the beginning if you start
asking Joe Rogan questions that's fine
as a as a you know you're tasting and
testing and getting started but we're
always so worried about chasing our
competition where really the goal should
be to be the best us and so nobody can
out Evan Evan nobody can out Samuel
Samuel and so when people uh will often
share videos with me to say oh look this
person copied your style this person is
doing exactly what you're doing like
that's cool like I don't you're not
going to out me me so if you're just
going to be a elfis impersonator great
like keep doing you but ultimately
everybody needs to find their own path
so I think so many times we're worried
about the rearview mirror and what's
happening behind us as opposed to
forging our own path to say okay how am
I going to be unique what do I love
doing that other people don't and going
all in on that thing also to make sure
you're taking action after watching this
video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there so
I start out the book around mediocrity
and it gets it gets it gets pretty angry
I think and pretty pretty pretty
aggressive I want to start the book off
strong I think you know ultimately I
think everybody has the ability to be
great I think everybody has Michael
Jordan level Talent or like whoever your
favorite entrepreneur or person or like
somebody who you think is just amazing
at what they do I think everybody body
has that I think everybody has that
ability you might not be able to play
basketball better than Michael Jordan
but you can be Michael Jordan of
something yes I agree yes Michael Jordan
is is special but he's not that special
at the same time like everything I've
done on YouTube is special but I'm not
I'm I'm just like everybody else I'm not
that special like you could do what I'm
doing you could do it better than what
I'm doing in your own thing don't don't
don't come after me and do believe in
top 10 I'll I'll Crush you on that but
you could do your own thing right like
people watching you could do your own
thing and so most people settle for just
a mediocre life it's just okay you're
just paying your bills you're you know
you you may not hate your life totally
but it's it's just okay and and I want I
want to shake people out of that I want
you to feel like you know you have an
ability to be a genius like you already
are a genius and we got to untap that
and the best way that I know how at the
start is through self-awareness and so I
think it begins with core values it
begins with your one word but even if
you think the whole thing doesn't make
sense like just understanding that you
could be the Michael Jordan of something
and and you should be allergic to
mediocrity that it's not acceptable for
you to to not live the life that you
want to go off and live failur is a
really interesting topic and it's
something that that we uh we see as a
bad thing for some reason where failure
is really feedback failure is a learning
experience failure is only really
failure if you don't take anything and
learn from it and again you don't have
to jump in and go all in and be the
risky entrepreneur uh I think everybody
fails in their path to success everybody
fails not just entrepreneurs anybody in
any and anytime you're trying to learn
something you will fail at the start you
will suck at the start right you want to
learn French you're going to fail along
the way to learning French right you
want to get up on a snowboard you're not
going to ace it the first time down
you're going to fall fall fall fall fall
and eventually you make it up right and
so the notion that you would start a
business or start any project and have
instant success is crazy and and people
try something out for the first time
when they're not successful at it and a
lot of them will then say yeah I'm not
an entrepr oh that's not for me I can't
do this and then go back to their life
that they hate where that's just a
learning experience right just the key I
think is to make small failures like
fail small fail small don't go go crazy
and bet the house and your mortgage and
put your entire family at risk exactly
that's that's where it gets dangerous
but in terms of teaching small failures
I think I think we kind of already do
through um through our upbringing in our
school system and a lot of the things
that we do but but I think just uh
showcasing that failure is not this
really negative thing that we want to
run away from because if you have no
failures it means you're playing life so
safe that you've never taken any any
risk at anything any shot at anything
right you you have a dream to accomplish
something you're going to fail a lot to
get there and I just see failur feedback
not as something that is a negative
thing the ability to both recruit team
and recruit
clients based not just off the
performance but the story so in your
willingness to share what you've been
through and the mission that you're on I
think it actually attracts the right
people to you both clients and team
which then that can parlay into
something much bigger if you look at you
know Ed mlet came from the financial
World Patrick bavid came from the
financial world now doing things outside
the financial World in a big follow them
daily yeah that's their background and
still you know kind heavy ties to the
business but you they don't talk much
about it you don't hear Ed and Patrick
talking about that business too much a
little bit but if you were to see their
show you wouldn't think oh this is the
yeah insurance guy right right but it
becomes a a vehicle to get to the next
step you know if you took the same
courage that you talk about Ali and
Sanders in and bring that to your
business and your content and your
messaging like upfront it's not just
that you're a winner and you can help
them get the deal it's also the story
behind it why would I pick you over
somebody else you have the track record
but other people have the track record
you know is your track record that much
better than somebody else's you
know maybe compared to Startup for sure
but there's other people who have more
experience than you do but they don't
have your
story and that combination is where you
start to bring on the right people as I
went through writing the book I actually
did not have the negative side at all
the think of what you hate because it's
not how I'm wired I never really think
negative I'm always super on the
optimistic side uh but as I started
helping out
entrepreneurs a lot of them had a hard
time going positive and finding what
their one word was they were constantly
struggling and so I just suggested hey
like okay forget about the things that
make you happy what do you hate like who
do you hate which teacher did you hate
growing up which friend or colleague or
someone at work or classmate that you
just absolutely hate not that they're
wrong or they're a bad person there's
just something about them that you don't
like and some people find it easier to
do that and think of like this is what I
like I hate struggle I hate struggle so
much right and then that's your anti-
and just go the opposite and you find
Thrive and so that was because of the
coaching I did helping different
entrepreneurs oneon-one and finding
their one word that was a nice little
addition to the book in one of the
exercises so if you have a hard time
finding it going positive it may even be
easier to go negative to figure it out
whatever problem you're facing right now
somebody's already solved it and and a
great way is actually to look through
books and find out you know whatever
problem in history that you're facing
right now has already been solved
history repeats itself over and over and
over again it started when I was 19 had
my first software company and I was
struggling and failing and making $300 a
month and not being able to survive and
I hit my bottom and and then I
eventually realized that I'm not the
first guy to try to sell software before
like this has been figured out
I just need to find someone who's done
it and model their success and I looked
at Microsoft and Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft not how Bill Gates
makes an extra million dollars now it's
not it's not relevant but zero to one
how did they do that that's what I want
to do and I did it through Partnerships
and so I started following what he did
to be successful in his early days and I
started Landing deals and I got my first
check was $135,000 and that to me was
that was amazing that may not seem like
a lot of money but when you're making
$300 a month $35,000 is a lot of money
but more importantly it gave me a model
to then replicate over and over and over
and over and over again and so now my
default is whatever challenge that I'm
facing right now look at who's already
accomplished it and how can we model
their success I think you need to make
big decisions with your heart and the
small ones with the head so I didn't
know if it'd be worth
it but that's like should I move to
California or should I marry like you
know are you are you seeing somebody I'm
assuming you're not married yet no just
like so you're thinking about like are
you going to marry somebody how do you
know if it's going to work out well you
don't but your heart tells you to do it
so you do
it so it's the same thing like should
you go be a podcaster how do you know if
it's going to work out well you
don't but you want to do it so you go
and do it and it doesn't mean you go all
in and you have to quit everything I
love small testing and you know proving
that the momentum is paying off but you
don't know how everything's going to
work out but if you stay on the same
path you're on you don't know how that's
going to work out either you know like
if you're going to school and the path
is you become a dentist versus I'm GNA
go be a podcaster and try to be an
entrepreneur well you don't know how the
dentist path works out either will you
be happy as a dentist probably not will
you be happy as a podcaster I don't know
maybe nobody knows but until you go off
and do it and so um big decisions with
the heart if you are feeling like it's
you need to do this then the worst thing
to do is to not do it and then get to
the end of your life and look back and
say man I wish I just started that
podcast I I could have just gone down
the street and bought some microphones
and just started and honestly I was just
too afraid and I never
started for 10 more rules from
Tom is their standard the world of
people who started with less than what
you already have right now and they're
winning and too many people are out
there complaining complaining that you
don't have the money that you don't have
the time that you don't have the
experience that you don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but others have done it
with those very same circumstances as
you with worse circumstances than you
the difference is they have a higher
standard for themselves and today we're
going to raise yours one of the things
I'm most proud about for myself why do I
love Evan carmichel is because when I
say I'm going to do something I do it
especially when it gets hard like it
doesn't count until it gets hard and I'm
doing it not just for other people I'm
I'm doing it not because I promised you
that I would show up I'm doing it for
myself because I said I was going to do
something and then I go off and do it
this is the foundation of self-esteem of
self-confidence of self- Lov doing it
when you say you're going to do it and
so on Monday
I usually have a 2-hour walking meeting
with Alex Alex helps me run TR Dan salsa
he comes over Monday is my mentoring day
and we'll usually go for a 2-hour walk
around the city and it's starting to get
cold you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold and so we bundle up and we
go for our 2-hour walk while we while we
talk and while we meet I'm trying to do
walking meetings more just for my own
health and and just because just for the
challenge of it because it's easy to
start something like that in the spring
or in the summer it's really hard to do
it when it's in the winter and you live
in Toronto Canada and it's snowing and
cold right so this Monday Alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but just sick and nah my wife super
caring said hey maybe you shouldn't go
for a walk outside and and in my heart
just like come on no we have to I said I
was going to do it right I have to I
have to for myself I have to go on the
walk like I'll go on the walk and leave
Alex at my place and and just film the
meeting with him uh but we came up with
a different solution which was I have a
I live in a condo we have a gym in my
condo and we went down to the condo gym
and I walked on the treadmill while he
stood or sat next to me for 2 hours
because I said that I was going to do it
how important is that one two-hour walk
not much right in itself not much am I
going to get healthy from doing that one
walk no am I going to lose weight by
doing that one walk no I'm going to have
so much more mental Clarity by doing
that one walk of course not but it's the
whole game because you're teaching
yourself that you follow through you're
teaching yourself that you have high
standards you're teaching yourself that
when you say you're going to do
something you follow through because
life is coming for you with a ton of
roadblocks life is going to throw tons
of curveballs at you if you can only do
the thing that you said you were going
to do when it's easy and the path is
perfectly clear you're never going to do
it this is why people don't stay
consistent because as soon as life gets
hard you let yourself off the hook you
allow your standards to drop to say oh
it's okay yeah of course I can't go for
walk cuz Alex is sick right and there
are definitely legitimate times when you
should let yourself off the hook if I
was dying in bed with a fever and I
couldn't get out of bed I wouldn't go
for the walk that makes sense don't be
stupid there's times when you need to be
gentle on yourself but more often than
not we are too gentle on ourselves when
we shouldn't be I could have done the
walk and we did it we did it in the in
the in the gym downstairs and Alex stood
next to me and sat next to me and didn't
have to go outside and and get the cold
on him and I still got my walk in right
and I feel great about it because I did
it when it was hard because here's this
obstacle that life's throwing at me
here's an easy way when everybody around
me saying you don't have to go off and
do it and a little tiny voice inside my
own head saying okay well here's a
chance you don't have to do it like no
be quiet voice I'm doing it we're
finding a solution let's go and the
solution is I'm going to walk on the
treadmill downstairs I'm writing a new
book about finding your purpose and turn
into a business and then I included the
last chapter on how to make money
because I think a lot of people feel
icky
or nasty about trying to well I just
love helping these people so I can't
charge for this I think it actually is
selfish not to charge for it I think it
becomes your your obligation that you
have to charge for it not to everybody I
think you there'll always be a
percentage if it's 10% or 20% of people
who who get in for free because they
can't afford it but if you don't learn
how to make money from your purpose then
it will always be a hobby and you'll
always have to do a full-time job to
then support your hobby where if you
actually made it a business and learned
how to make money use doing it serving
people in an ethical you know
life-changing positive way then you can
reach more people you can build a team
you can scale up now instead of as maybe
as a hobby you can hit 10 women a month
wow hobby but if you have a business and
now you're building a team of amazing
women who all want the same thing maybe
now you're reaching millions of women
wow so I think it I think it's your
responsibility to to turn that into
something that then can create a ripple
effect greater than just a hobby on the
side a good question ask yourself is do
you actually love this do you want it
badly enough I love making videos I
sucked at the beginning I'm still
working to get better I've gotten better
over the you know decade I've been on
YouTube I still look forward to it I
still love it I still work every week
creating content for you guys we're
putting out six videos a day across the
different channels now it's it's wild
it's crazy and I still love it we're
putting in the work I'm putting in the
work my team's putting in the work
because we still actually love the
process of doing it so so many
entrepreneurs quit and give up because
you'll say you'll do whatever it takes
but you're not going to if you don't
actually love the process you don't
actually love the work you will not do
whatever it takes you will only force
yourself to do something that you hate
for so long until you give up and quit
so big reason why entrepreneurs don't
put in enough work is cuz you just don't
love enough how do you feel
about this kind of like world that is
going speeding so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of place so first step like
the first step for me is flipping it to
get excited so when something new comes
out it's like okay I'm excited to I'm
excited to go learn that thing AI comes
out cool let's go let's go learn about
AI it's like expecting to suck at it I
don't know anything about AI I don't
know how to program AI I didn't know how
to do anything inside of AI and okay
let's go learn we're we're filming this
video on the on the the day after
Instagram or Facebook just launches
threads right right so threads just come
out it's a Twitter competition and most
people are like oh my gosh threads
another social media thing why do we
need another place to go and doom scroll
on and great like I'm a let me learn
about friends this is exciting I just
try to teach myself that when there's
something new let's go learn it it's
exciting because the rate of change is
not going to go slower right I agree so
so this becomes your key uh adaptation
technique is that anytime something new
comes out get excited go learn about it
this is how you can start to win and for
anybody who is earlier on in their
Journey whenever something new comes out
that actually becomes your secret hack
to go off and win so if you're trying to
get started and you're on Twitter it
might be hard for you to to win right
now because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can't so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they built
up Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right
now because he doesn't want to start
over right this is the problem like
people don't want to start over and I
don't know anything about Brad Pit no
shadeed Brad uh but like some people
make the jump like Will Smith make the
jump and like starts blowing up on
YouTube but a lot of people don't a lot
of people stick to one platform and then
they they slowly become irrelevant and
so when something new comes up this is
your chance to go off and win like you
might not beat Joe Rogan at podcasting
but you can beat him on threads or you
can get close to him on threads and a
lot of the people who are are winning in
that first platform just don't want to
go and start over on the second one and
so this is your chance to get ahead and
so whether it's AI whether it's threads
whether it's an update to the YouTube
algorithm whether it's whatever the
thing is there's more
coming and there and there's more coming
too so training yourself to be the
person who gets excited for new changes
because that's your chance to go and win
have a bigger impact make more money
like whatever actually drives you spread
more faith right
whatever actually is driving you this is
your opportunity to go off and do it and
so for me that's always been the default
where like okay why I don't it's always
been a default I think I've trained
myself um to get more excited about the
new things that are coming up uh and I
just go in with a student mind expect to
suck you know like I don't somebody
asked me about threads today like hey
what's your thread strategy like I don't
know I'm two days in like I'm trying to
figure it I don't even know what this is
yet I'm I'm maybe not the smartest
person but I'm I'm trying to understand
understand it as we go or when some new
AI tool drops okay let's understand what
the heck this thing even does and
learning how to use it so but it's just
getting excited about it and putting in
a little bit of effort to learn how to
do it because so many people they just
get stuck on I don't know how and it's
new and scary and so I don't do anything
where really you're actually not that
far away from making momentum if you
just put in a little bit of effort
perfectionism is really just fear you
know you're just afraid right so I try I
mean of course I'm still afraid of many
things but if I can catch it I try not
to be or do the thing that makes me
scared but to the Kill Your Darlings um
yeah one of my greatest fears earlier
on uh in my career
was being an aging rock star and so one
of the things that for some reason
really bothered me was you look at these
rock stars who were big in like the 70s
or 80s or 90s or whatever and they still
go on tour and like wow they're still on
tour like it's amazing that they're
still on tour but they're still still
singing the songs they were singing like
decades ago yes you know like where is
the new stuff like have you had nothing
new to say in 30 years since you
recorded the thing right and right
anytime you're anytime you're uh
judgmental of somebody else it's
self-reflection it's like it's your own
you're worried about yourself not about
like Aeros Smith or whatever doesn't
care about me or my opinion and I don't
really hate on aerosense so it's like if
you are criticizing somebody else is
like well look inside cuz you have that
same thing that you're criticizing and I
realized it was my fear that I I don't
want to be that like I don't want to be
Evan uh you know 30 years later still
making videos yay but like telling the
war stories of back in 2023 when you
know was on with Sean talking about Tom
Brady uh I want to make new stuff right
I want to make new stuff and I think
I've I've overcome that one um I only
bring up the past when people ask me
questions about um about the past uh but
that was yeah that was a big thing that
was a big fear of mine early on getting
started it's like I didn't want to just
hold on to my darlings and sing the same
songs over and over and over again when
you understand what your single most
important core value is everything else
becomes so much easier so for me it's
belief right believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that I make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that I make is about
belief it has to be every interaction I
have every Workshop every book every
meeting all of it has to be run through
the believe framework right the glasses
of believe if I'm hiring somebody on to
my team skills alone aren't enough it's
great that you can write copies do you
believe in entrepreneurs it's a big
difference so when you understand your
core value everything else becomes
clearer and you're less likely to follow
what other people want you to do
everybody around you they have a goal
for you even if it's well-intentioned
they have opinions on what you should do
with with your life everybody around you
this is what you should do with your
life everybody has an opinion you don't
know which way to go if you don't know
which way to go it's because you don't
know what you stand for because you're
standing on quicksand but when you
understand your one word your who your
most important core value it's like
you're standing on a rock that nobody
can push you from so how do you figure
that out quickly right I mean this is
200 something Pages let's boil it down
super quick for you you want to think
about all the people that you love your
favorite teacher what you love to about
your parents think about your favorite
musician your favorite band your
favorite song your favorite movie your
favorite book all the all your favorite
things the things that when you are
around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident Unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're going to
make it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to 10 things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three keywords that
describe each of them so your favorite
teacher why did you love Mr Jones it's
not because he taught you grade four
math right there was something else
about Mr Jones that you love why do I
love SE Biscuit the movie because it's
about an oversized jockey and an
undersized horse and an owner that has
no money and all of these things and
they all come together it's believe
right my parents taught me that Evan cly
Cara I can do anything that I believe
that I can right and so through all the
things that I love believe is the common
thread what is it for you you have to
figure it out you have to figure it out
it doesn't have to take you years of
work just write down all of the people
and the things that you love three
keywords for each like do this this is
important just do it today it'll make a
huge difference in your life it's worth
it this is the best 15 minutes you can
spend in your life do it pause the video
and do it and then just see what comes
up consistently what word comes up over
and over and over and over and over and
over again chances are that's your one
word that's your who then when you
discover it you have to start living
that life the idea with 2% difference is
when we come up with an idea like I'm
going to launch a YouTube channel I'm
going to write my own book I want to
start a Instagram book account like I
want to do whatever we all have these
ideas of what we want to do the first
thing that we typically do is start
planning researching planning who's done
it before who can I model and learn from
all these ideas and we create this giant
list of plans and what we're trying to
do is plan to the 100% which is like
that's what our final destination is
going to look like how do I plan to get
my goal and then we end up waking up the
next day and you look at your plan
you're like I can't do that I thought
what I'm not there's no way I can do
that it's not even like us telling our
friends or our spouses or it's it's us
telling ourselves that we can't do this
and so the problem is we used our energy
our our our mojo our our best like high
Vibes on planning instead of on doing
where again the biggest thing people are
missing just momentum planning doesn't
really count as momentum you have to go
and do something and so instead of
worrying about planning to get to 100%
of our goal completed the 2% difference
is just start with the first 2% what's
what's the first 2% and we don't care
about getting to the end goal we just
care about getting started so that was
me in writing the book okay well I'm
going to write the book after this
Instagram live I'm going to start right
now it's easy for all the thoughts to
start to overwhelm yourself and I did
like I don't have time for this I this
is not on my plan I'm busy I have to I
feel like I'm going to be a bad father a
bad husband a bad uh manager bad CEO
like I don't have time for this right
and I share all those thoughts in the
book too so you can kind of peek behind
the window it wasn't like I really was
desperately wanting to do this going in
and then uh I just started writing so
like if anybody out here you want to
write your first book cool the the 2%
difference is write the first page and
it's okay if it sucks if you want to
start a YouTube channel 2% difference is
record your first video and it's going
to suck awesome cool but more important
than planning how to make a book or
planning how to record a YouTube video
is to just start doing the thing and you
build momentum if you want to start
building a healthy habit you want to you
want to you want to start working out
right this is where we often get
overwhelmed like I want to work out I
want to look good next year I want to I
want to feel comfortable naked or
whatever we want to be able to do cool
so it starts off with this very simple
concept but then the doing becomes
really complicated because as you start
to plan and research a health Journey
right it's like oh well do I do weights
do I do cardio how much of each do I do
uh do I do classes do I hire a coach do
I how much am I supposed to wait am I
going to hurt myself am I going to
injure my back trying to do this thing
maybe I should take maybe I should go do
soccer or pick up a sport or pick up uh
basketball or oh but do I need a partner
to run with like can I overtrain and how
about nutrition like do I need to drink
am I drinking too much water not enough
water do I need to go carnivore or vegan
and all of a sudden it's like so many
this is what happens we get so
overwhelmed with all the potential
options which then leads us to try to
plan plan plan plan plan plan plan some
more but then you can't understand all
of the various options and then we end
up getting this is C I'm not do it I'm
I'm out I'm done and then stop before
you even started right and so the key is
2% difference if you want to start a
health Journey get down on the floor and
do five push-ups or 10 or two right is
it going to make you extra strong no but
it's the first step and most people wait
a decade to take the first step and so
that's what the 2% difference is all
about you don't win a Nobel Prize by
telling yourself that you want to win a
Nobel Prize you win a Nobel Prize by
having a mission so big that it forces
you to become become somebody new a
stronger more bold more resilient
version of you if you make success your
goal you will most likely miss it
because you have the wrong outcome in
mind make impact your goal make your
mission your goal and you'll end up
having more success than you ever
thought possible I look at my YouTube
channel as an example and the next goal
would be to have 10 million subscribers
right I got my 100,000 plaque I got
three of them there I got my million
plaque the next goal is 10 million and
there's nothing wrong with having goals
but the problem is if I made 10 million
the thing like all I'm doing is chasing
down 10 million subscribers it forces
you to do short-term decisions that end
up not serving you right if I wanted to
just blow up my channel the best way to
do it isn't actually to spread positive
content negativity spreads much faster
than positivity if I made a top 10 video
on why this person sucked or an inspress
about how this person's an idiot or
people fighting people can't help but
see that people that's why people stop
to see the car accident on the highway
right we don't reward the good drivers
you want to see the chaos you want to
see what caused the flame there's a
fight on the street corner you you stop
to see what's going on right we're
attracted to the negativity more than
the positivity that's a faster way to
blow up my channel the problem is I
wouldn't feel good about it I don't want
to spread negativity I don't want to
spread conflict and Chaos I don't want
to spread pessimism I don't want to
spread despair I don't want to spread
ego I don't want to spread negativity I
just I don't want to do that and so it
would lead to me flaming out before I
ever hit the goal that's the problem you
can have this goal this is what most
people do you have some goal here's my
goal I'm going to do whatever it takes
to get to that goal the problem is you
won't do whatever it takes cuz it's
going to get too hard you can only do
things for so long that you don't love
before you quit and give up and so
there's nothing wrong with having a goal
but more important than the goal is the
mission I want to sell the world's
biggest problem it's something that's
never going to happen never in my
lifetime it's never going to happen I
want people to believe in themselves
more it's never going to hit that
ultimate goal where everybody is Michael
Jordan at something it will never happen
and I wake up every day trying to do
that and so if you make a goal tied to
some outcome like getting 10 million
subscribers on YouTube it's going to
force you down a path that likely won't
serve you so you leave with the mission
you leave with the impact and success
will follow what do you think we
gravitate towards negativity a lot more
when we know it doesn't make us feel
good because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like you it's like from the history
of US struggling right has to be you I
mean I don't know I don't not I'm not a
scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but like why
do we slow down and look at a car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally get hit by looking
at Happ like if a fight breaks out on
the street it's like you're you know you
want to see what happens like where we I
don't know where it comes from but like
it it it definitely is that people would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video was the top 10 rules
for Kanye West and was positive things
you can learn from Kanye if that was a
negative like top 10 stupidest things
Kanye has said it would it would do so
much better because I think I think if
I'm looking at it from the perspective
of what I do is like we we would rather
see people fail
then then try to build ourselves up
right you know it's like oh look at D
she she's got her podcast and she's been
on movies and look at her building her
life and she she made it out and now
she's in LA and she's such a big deal
and y y y and it's easier for me to try
to tear you down and want to see you
fail than for me to say huh like maybe I
can fix my life maybe I can go to La too
maybe I can start a podcast maybe I can
and and whatever the things are that you
know jealousy is really just um ins
inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if if I'm jealous of you
I'm actually inspired by you but I don't
know how to handle it so I take it
negative
totally so it's easier for me to tear
you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because I don't have to do any
work that way right it's like yeah but
then yeah but she like totally sold her
soul the good do that and she and I'll
make I make up some stuff that like
doesn't even make sense but it allows me
to stay where I'm at where I am right so
that's why a lot of a lot of even our
friends and family will often say not to
go do something because if you go off if
you go off to LA and you start becoming
a movie star and you start meeting
people what does it mean for
me you know like you left me behind and
and now my life sucks cuz you're showing
what's possible and I'm living in a fake
reality I don't want to accept that so
it's not possible you must have had to
do something super scammy
to terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know you hide
someone in the closet and it's not
coming out yeah so I think that's like
it we don't doing work on yourself is
hard very learning new skills and making
new connections and going to a new
country or new city is hard it's really
hard and we don't want to do hard things
but your great life is on the other side
of of hard things and so when we see
somebody else who looks like us comes
from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than be Inspire
not everybody but a lot of people yeah
because we want it we prefer to stay
stuck than the grow the reason most
people don't win isn't because you don't
have great ideas you're a genius the
only thing missing is momentum you're
dreaming huge that's amazing I love it
but there is zero momentum it's never
going to be the right time and nobody is
coming to save you the time is now to
make your dreams happen so here's a
really fun example yesterday I needed to
take a break from my work to go to the
bathroom so I go to the bathroom open up
my Feedly and start looking at you know
some of the new stories that were
happening and there was this amazing
video that I saw about a busker in
Toronto who uh a company organized what
they call a cash mob instead of a flash
mob they would all show up at this guy
doing his you know guitar singing
playing and just throw money at him not
at him but in the guitar case right and
they were they probably made like a
thousand bucks they were throwing 20s
and 50s Not Just pennies and and you
know dollar bills and stuff that giving
him tons of money and and and he's
starting to get overwhelmed he's playing
the guitar he's getting overwhelmed and
and I'm I'm getting motivated and
excited and just heartfelt what a great
moment and I decide in that moment we
need to make this video more public we
need to spread it this has to go up on
the channel I need to spread awareness I
want to I want to promote this company
who put this together I love it what a
great idea and so right away like here's
the thing you get a great idea trust
your great ideas go do something about
it I could have easily filed that away
next week I'll work on it and then what
guess what's going to happen next week
I'm not going to work on it because I'm
going to move on to something else right
I'm in the middle of my day I've got
priorities and the plan for that day and
then this thing pops up I trust that
idea trust that great and that I got to
do something about it cuz if I'm
inspired if you're inspired you're going
to create gold you're going to create
Magic if you're not inspired then just
keep doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about I think you need to follow
that through and so I I parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and I made the ending and I
made the thumbnail and I made the
description and I made the title and I
created it all in one shot and I sent it
off to my editor Christina we love you
Christina say hey we got to put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took I don't know half an
hour it took half an hour out of my day
that I was supposed to do other stuff to
make that happen because momentum
matters momentum matters it's the most
important thing you're a genius the
ideas that you have our gold they're
genius you're just not doing enough with
it how you can model success this is
what saved my business
when I wanted to quit at my company my
first software company and then I
realized that you know what I'm not the
first guy to try to sell software before
like somebody has figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at the strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and we started to grow and so
whatever dreams whatever goals whatever
business you have somebody's already
figured it out may not be exactly what
you want to do and that's good because
you're different you're an entrepreneur
you're GNA put your own twist on it but
people have already figured it out and
so understanding what they did and
trying to break down their success could
be really helpful so that if you're
hustling and grinding you're spending
your time on the right things that will
help you as opposed to the things that
aren't leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interviews is that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors there's the
regular mentors that people think about
where you go for coffee and they're you
know they're local you can go meet them
and they break down your business uh and
I never had that right like my parents
taught me so much about life and being a
human being but never about business and
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
and so I had nobody to go and have
coffee with I went to my banker and said
hey can you help me with my business
he's like well do you need a loan like
no I don't know do I need a loan I don't
know he's like yeah you're not really in
the right place like I didn't know
anybody and so I Look To What I Call
aspirational mentors these the people
who you aspire to be like or aspire to
learn from and some people may have
already passed on and you'll never beat
them like I have Steve Jobs up on my
wall I'm never going to meet him
obviously um and a lot of the people
behind me uh some I may meet one day or
some have passed on uh and so I look at
two kinds of what I call aspirational
mentors the first are in your industry
whatever you want to do somebody has
done it you want to be a successful
YouTuber there's lots of people who've
done it Go and model them see what they
did the more uh successful they are the
more information there is on them
whether it's interviews or books or
magazine articles like their story is
somewhere and again look to how they got
started as opposed to what they're doing
now because it's a different scale and
then the second kind are just the people
who you look up to you know if if I love
Oprah Winfrey I could learn something
from her even if I don't want to have my
own talk show you know if you love
Michael Jordan you could learn from him
even if you never want to be a
basketball player like the way that he
works and his hustle and effort and he's
in the gym you can apply that to your
life and to your business even if you
never go on to try to become an NBA
player so those two things the people
who have done what you want to do maybe
you hate them but you can still learn
from their success right and just do it
your way and then the people who you
just really look up to and really admire
and say one day I want to have that kind
of impact again understanding how they
got started and modeling their success
to help you get your breakthrough are
you of the opinion then that if somebody
has a job but they have a feeling that
they want to be um an entrepreneur but
they're afraid of leaving their job are
you of the opinion that they should uh
take a take steps towards that and and
if you have a feeling for something try
it and just see and expect to suck but
at least you tried and you can see you
know do you want to go off and do it
again you had a feeling in in the coffee
shop to come and ask me to connect if
you didn't follow the feeling that would
have been it like I would have my my
breakfast with Joe and then CIA and off
right and I may never see you again you
had the feeling you followed it and it
may not always be good like maybe I'm an
maybe I'm an ass maybe you're like dude
get out of my face you're weird stalking
me out of the bathroom right like maybe
like you don't know you don't know what
would happen but you have a feeling and
you have to follow the feeling cuz
otherwise you teach yourself that the
things that come to you are not great
because if every time you get an idea
and you don't follow through you're
teaching yourself that your ideas suck
versus I have an idea I'm going to give
it a shot that's a great identity to
start to build it doesn't mean go
mortgage your home to go start a podcast
Studio like expect to suck and find the
smallest possible thing to just go and
get started so somebody who's working a
corporate job that hates their life okay
you're you're never going to win doing
work that you hate so so longer term
something has to change it doesn't mean
go like take a flamethrower to your
boss's office or something now like you
need the money you need the cool awesome
but longer term like we have to make a
change somewhere because you will never
be great doing work that you hate you're
never going to make the money you're
never going to be happy if you're doing
work you hate every day so how you going
to get out of that hole that you're in
is it going to be somebody else telling
you what you should do with your life
that's going to be like you have ideas
for what you it'd be cool if I could do
this okay go give it a shot try it see
if you liked it your first podcast
sucked cool and you get better like
you're better at eight episodes in than
I was at like 300 episodes in right so
but you try and so I think if you have
the feeling you want to teach yourself
that you come up with great ideas and
and they're worth at least least giving
a shot to instead of just saying you
know there's sushi on the table I don't
like sushi without even giving a shot
cuz it sounds gross like if you had to
explain what Sushi is raw fish with with
fish eggs and seaweed with rice and
super spicy mustard that doesn't sound
appetizing right like why would anybody
eat that but you eat it I like Su with
you guys but but you don't know until
you try it so like you're judging things
before you're trying it and especially
when it's yourself you're judging your
ideas before you even try it you're
building uh the belief that your ideas
suck and that you suck and then you stay
stuck and so I I at least you know
encourage myself to try to flip that
that I have ideas that saying yes to you
okay let's go I'm not going to judge it
let's go do it you will never lose in
life if you have valuable skills you
won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value the economy can collapse the
algorithms can change but as long as you
have a skill that solves problems for
people you will be safe so I'm seeing
this a lot in the YouTube world now uh I
have a new course out helping people get
to a million subscribers on YouTube we
can link up the description there if you
want in and people are saying well
should I still do YouTube is it too late
like YouTube won't be here in 5 years or
10 years or maybe it's going to be the
next thing that should hop on it's not
about the platform like right now it's
winning the platform that is currently
winning you need to crush it right like
YouTube should be your home if you're
trying to make an impact you're trying
to be a thought leader you have a
message to spread YouTube has to be your
number one place it just has to be right
now otherwise you're not making a smart
decision but whether YouTube is still
around in 20 years 5 years doesn't
matter because the skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing I don't anticipate YouTube still
been around in 20 years but my ability
to make videos talking to a lens that's
not going to go away that can serve me
for life right whether that's VR Evan or
hologram Evan you know coming into your
living room that's that's going to be me
it's going to be amazing I'm pumped I
look forward to it any algorithm change
that people are freaking out about
anybody who's complaining about the
economy going down or the algorithm
changing you've already lost that's a
losing mindset when I was first starting
my YouTube
channel uh I always saw the algorithm as
a chance to win right you should see if
you're a small Creator on any platform
YouTube Instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts that's your greatest
Advantage you should be cheering you
should want more algorithm changes if
you look at a traditional established
boring Market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win right
financial markets can be hard to win
it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have who have Decades of
experience and no more than you and it's
hard to close that gap of
experience with social media with
YouTube every time there's a big
algorithm change the people who are
experts at the last thing they're crying
instead of adjusting that's how you win
that's how you get ahead of them that's
how you become the top dog is because
you're going to go learn the new
algorithm when everybody is wishing and
hoping that the old algorithm comes back
and this happens for every platform it
happened for Facebook every time they
changed your algorithm or updated the
the feed and what was shown there people
always freak out and complain and they
sign they want petitions and like let's
go back to how it used to be don't sign
those petitions don't jump on that
Bangin that is loser thinking never ever
ever ever ever ever ever do that it's
loser thinking and that's how most
people
think that's a mindset ship that I want
to make for the collective but more
importantly for you that whenever
there's a big change embrace it go all
in on it learn it that's how you're
going to LEAP fog everybody else so the
faster the rate of change the more you
should be cheering I still get pumped
for an algorithm change me I mean now
I'm at now I'm closer to the top right I
mean I don't know what the top is I got
2 million subscribers and 300 million
views and all these channels
I still love it anytime an algorithm
change comes out I'm still pumped train
yourself Like A change is coming I'm
pumped get excited cuz there's still
people who are ahead of me or even the
people below me that I'm competing with
for for attention and for space if
they're sitting there complaining about
how it's changed and and they're
dropping in their views awesome I'll
pick up those views because I'm going to
learn what the new algorithm is all
about same thing with the economy when
the economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforting
to join a club and wish things to be how
they used to be but we're not going back
to that so the faster you realize that
and make improvements the faster you can
learn and actually build a great
business some of the greatest businesses
in the world were built in recession in
depression that could be you if you
decide to be let's hop back to skills
for a second I look at Jake Paul Logan
Paul they started on Vine right Vine was
was their claim to fame they had tons of
success in making these super short
videos Vine gets shut down right boom
gone this don't put all your eggs in one
basket I think that's loser thinking too
it's loser thinking they went all in on
Vine and and then Vine got shut down oh
no what did they do they moved to
YouTube and started crushing it millions
of subscribers look at their growth on
YouTube over the past I don't know two
years three years blew up why they
didn't just come out of nowhere they had
the skill set they had the skill set
that they learned from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
YouTube goes away you're learning the
skill set of how to communicate how to
make great videos that whatever comes
next people are freaking out about the
FTC coming in and cop on YouTube okay so
if kids aren't able to get content on
YouTube where they going to go go be
there instead of trying to fight what is
already happening go be at the place
where the kids are going to be embrace
the change that's where you that's where
you can win when everybody else is
fighting and angry and screaming and
yelling and complaining and wishing that
it used to be or quitting the platform
and getting upset go be where they're
going to be it's it's easy it's a simple
win most people don't have that mindset
it's why most people lose it's why most
businesses can't evolve most most
businesses shut down it's people very
rarely transition from one platform to
another from one business to another
even though they have the skill sets and
capabilities to do so because they don't
have the mindset to do so people who
crushed my space very few of them are
still around on different platforms look
at at look at Hollywood the rock is
doing it Will Smith is doing it moving
from Hollywood films to YouTube where's
Brad Pit where's George Clooney like
they're in a Dy industry they should be
embracing YouTube they don't want to
they have the skills they have the
skills it's transferable you don't think
George Clooney could come in and Crush
YouTube if you wanted to of course he
could calling you out George Clooney
let's go make it happen right so it's
about picking up the skill set that will
keep you safe in any environment but
it's also having a mindset to follow
through and try the new things instead
of complaining about the changes that
are currently happening the more that
you can make choices
that build self-respect and and build
character the more you're capable of
making more choices like that people
think of it as some giant thing like
whatever your goals are I talk to a lot
of entrepreneurs so they want to start
their business but whatever your goals
are your personal your health goals your
Fitness your relationship your business
goals whatever they are it's not just
some one thing one giant goal that you
chase it's the daily minor decisions
that you have to make it's every day you
have this choice to am I going to do the
thing I said I was going to do
or am I going to not do it you know like
am I going to let myself down again here
or am I going to do the thing that makes
me proud and it's in in these minor
decisions that we have every day that
ultimately leads to you building your
character so I when you started your
show it's great amazing a lot of people
would love to start a show like you did
a lot of people would love to have
guests on their show as well and theyd
immediately have that insecurity in
their head come to say well who's going
to listen to me and what am I going to
talk about and which guests is going to
want to come on my show and they've been
on other shows how am I better how am I
different and my show and they've been
different and what that does is shut
down your action to go and create the
show and the more you listen to that
voice the the less action you do and the
more you teach yourself that you suck do
it you're training yourself to not do it
again the next time and not doing it
because this becomes your identity like
I'm the person who has great ideas but
never follows through and that is
something that we have to start to
consciously destroy on the health
Journey well I'm just a fat person and I
can't stick to a diet and I can't do
anything I can't run more than a mile I
can't like and we've created this
identity but all of those things are
fixable but it's not one giant leap
right you don't just get healthy by
going to the gym one day it's the
everyday consistency that you train
yourself for success is the progressive
realization of a worthy ideal what I
took away most from that definition is
the the word Progressive you want
progress you want to learn you want to
keep growing what was once a challenge
for you is now simple and it's very easy
to fall into a routine that once served
you but is now limiting you the day you
stop progressing is the day that you
start to hate your life and it can be
sneaky it can sneak up on you without
you even noticing what happened so I was
trying to think of a personal story to
share with you about this and I realize
it's been more than 10 years since I've
actually felt that I felt that
I've stopped progressing that that I
started to hate what I was doing it's
been over 10 years it was it was
basically since I started on YouTube and
I'm going to share with you the the the
hacks that I used so that you won't fall
into that rut but what happened for me
10 years ago was I built my website
right I sold my business I had success I
was speaking around the world I started
building my website and I built it into
a giant platform we had 100,000 plus
pages of content making money from
advertising and I just stopped liking
the business it's started to feel like
we're putting out content we're putting
out articles just trying to make money
putting out articles that that um I
didn't always believe 100% in we had a
bunch of guest people writing content
right we had four or 5,000 authors for
the website and not all of their
opinions or views or mindset or voice
reflected my own and I just stopped
liking the business it was a successful
business making money building a team I
had eight people I think at that time
and I decided you know what I this isn't
this isn't I'm I'm losing the love for
this I need to try new things and I
started making YouTube videos it was one
experiment i' probably done a bunch of
different things but YouTube was one
experiment that I sucked at but I loved
and I kept coming back to and and it
taught me it taught me a lesson it
taught me that you need to explore this
is this is what I tell a lot of people
when they're entrepreneurs I had a woman
uh Melissa who joined me on an IG live
the other day and she's talking about
how she's got a real estate business
that's making her money but she wants to
be a speaker and the speaking business
is growing it can't support her fully
yet but the real estate business gives
her a lot of money she like well I like
doing both like well no you
don't right like in 5 years where do you
want to be do you want to still be doing
real estate no no no 5 years I want to
be doing that I want to be doing the
speaking thing like great that's where
you need to start spending more of your
time it doesn't mean quit the job it
doesn't mean stop doing real estate or
stop doing the thing that you're just
okay with but while you still have one
foot in it you have to explore you have
to try you have to taste you got to see
what else you can do spend one day a
week two days a week depending on your
financial situation is my advice to her
spend one day or two days a week
focusing on the speaking business so
that in 6 months you could be out of the
real estate business and being speaking
full-time and then doing the thing that
you love right if you just like it that
should be a warning sign to get out not
as sap but you need to start exploring
but so many people end up hating the
thing that they're doing so many
entrepreneurs start a business they love
it it's challenging it's exciting it's
exhilarating and then they found that
they bought themselves a job and they
actually hate their business and then it
becomes too late to get out because you
can't find the person to sell it to or
you just have to walk away from it but
so many people just like it and you're
not exploring enough to chase down the
opportunity what skills does someone
need to get into this area of wanting to
be an entrepreneur what does it take I
don't think skills are the problem I
think I think you could learn anything
if you have a a commitment and passion
to learn um learn is your one word you
know I think I think learn the desire
and willingness to to go through crap
and learn and get better you could you
can pick up anything and I think I'm the
Testament to that in that I suck at the
start of my channel if you go back it's
embarrassing watching my first content
it's really really bad but I just kept
learning and said I can get better I'm
gonna improve I'm gonna keep working I'm
gonna keep getting better and and it
worked and so more than any specific
skill I think it's the mindset it's it's
the desire to learn and understand that
I can do better if you take that into
any field uh and match you with some
self-awareness I think you're set like
there's so many different ways to win as
an entrepreneur there's so many
different ways yes you may not win the
same way that Gary ve win and so to have
the self awareness to know hey I'm I'm
Mara I'm great at talking to people I'm
going to do a talk show and then you can
model success and you can learn from
Oprah and you learn from Larry King and
you can learn from all the great talk
show hosts and model some of their
Styles and every time you do that you
learn a little bit more to be a better
Mara and keep growing and keep getting
better the easiest way to win is to do
work that you love making a new video is
easy for me I've done 6,000 plus videos
I still love them I still enjoy it but
there is a chandelier sitting in the
trunk of my car right now that I have no
interest in installing I have I have no
idea how to install a light I have no
interest in learning how to install a
light and so I've asked my friend Mark
Dr from Fanta to come and help install
the light for me if you're doing a
business that you don't know and that
you don't love and you think it's just
going to be easy money news flash it's
never just easy money you are going to
lose you have to go through what I call
the blinders test now blinders are
things that people put on horses so
there's those black patches that they
they put here on the side of the horse
so that the horse doesn't get distracted
so the horse isn't like going all over
like this all they can see is what's in
front of them and it forces them to just
focus and going in front of them now
side note apparently they actually have
this for humans too and some tech
companies are using them where they have
blinders for humans that seems a little
crazy to me but listen if blinders help
you focus then by all means go for it
but you need to pass the blind nurse
test so what is the blind nurse test for
me it's there's moments in time where
you have absolute Clarity over what you
need to do where you know where you want
to go where you have Direction and
purpose and this is the window that you
need to jump through through for me
right now it's
YouTube yes I've been on the platform
for over 10 years but this is a special
moment in time for YouTube right now for
Evan carmichel plus YouTube right now
I'm hitting it on strides we've got I
don't know how many channels right now a
lot too many maybe but I want to have a
100 channels this is a moment in time
YouTube's not going to be around forever
and it's going to morph and it's going
to become something else and I'm going
to have different interests at some
point this is the moment of time that
you need to then push hard I see
opportunities Windows there's this
window that's in front of you right now
and the window's open but it's not going
to be open Forever at some point that
window of opportunity is going to shut
and that's when people look back and say
I had I could have done it and and that
other person they made so much money off
of my idea it wasn't your idea they did
it the only difference between you and
the people who are winning is they
started they did it they take action
every single day there's no reason why
that person can't be you you have to
jump through the window with full force
and put your blinders on and stop
thinking about everything everything
else that's around you that's if you
have absolute Clarity and Direction now
there will be other moments in your life
and I think I think life moves like this
I think you'll have moments in life
where you have absolute Clarity and
purpose and Direction and there'll be
other moments where you're not so sure
what to do and then you have to open up
the funnel again sticking to the the
blinders when you don't know what you're
doing is not a great strategy this this
happens to a lot of entrepreneurs where
they have Focus for their business but
then they lose interest in their
business and then they bought themselves
a job and they're too afraid to get out
of that business because of what it
means because of the opportunity cost
because of everything that they've
they've sunk into the business because
people might say well what a failure if
they close now and they should have been
out of their business three years ago
but they're still going don't let that
be you you're never going to win doing
work that you hate if you don't like
your business anymore you need to adjust
it or you need to move on dump it and
move on to something else if I stop
liking
videos I will just decide no no more
videos happening sorry guys maybe sell
it to somebody else or just stop cuz I'm
not going to win doing work that I hate
either and so if you feel your foot kind
of pulling out of the water while you
still have some interest move on to the
next thing and so when you know what you
want to do you're focused hyper focused
that's all you're doing when you don't
know what you want to do you open up the
scope and that's okay and I think
everybody will go through these phases
in life you will have absolute Clarity
and so you need to go off and do instead
of finding all the reasons why you can't
do and when you don't know what you want
to do don't stress out and worry that
you don't know what you want to do try a
bunch of stuff say yes to everything pay
attention to the feeling the most
important thing when you're trying
something new is do you love the process
of it not is this going to be your next
big opportunity did you love the process
even though you suck doing it I sucked
making my first video I love the process
I sucked when I first learned salsa
dancing I love the process you're
supposed to suck at the start that's
okay you don't need to get instant
results if you love the process you will
win if you got instant results but you
don't love it you're never going to win
it's just never going to happen you're
not going to win and so depending on
where you are on this spectrum of
absolute Clarity to having no idea
dictates what your action should be when
you know what you need to do stop making
excuses stop having justifications and
just go off and do the damn thing and if
you don't know what you want to do then
explore stop feeling sorry for yourself
stop complaining it's okay explore you
will find the thing that then you can
focus on until the next time you
expanded
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are
[Music]
awesome and value is the only thing that
people will pay for forever but there's
one immutable truth about Millennials
and I think it'll ring true with you
guys cuz I'm sure you feel it yourself
they want to matter they want to know
that they wake up every day